[Music]
I'm Alicia from the machine teaching
group and this is Johan so there is an
increasing demand for ML models and we
we see this demand because there are
lots and lots of tasks in our daily
lives that could benefit from machine
learning and we think that this
increasing demand cannot be met with
just developing the machine learning
algorithms and focusing on that problem
so what we're doing is focusing on
something called machine teaching so
that's making teaching machines easy
fast and accessible for anyone and we
want to increase the efficacy and the
productivity of the teachers giving the
learners or the ML algorithms so we take
our inspiration from software
engineering and there's a lot of
different concepts that can be applied
in this space so what we're going to
show you today is pickle or the platform
for interactive concept learning which
demonstrates these principles in a
web-based UI and it allows one person
with just domain knowledge about how to
build or about addresses to build an
actual address extractor from text
documents so I'll hand it off to young
Han and let him show you how to do that
okay so this is our how to pick Olaf
we're gonna go through how to build an
address extractor using using pickle so
the first thing we'll do I'll open a
project guy I started so I'm going to go
into some of the details of each of the
UI elements as we as we go along but
briefly on the left you'll see an area
where we can see existing labels and as
we start adding them in the middle is
our kind of exploration pane where we
see the examples of data as we explore
the data set the entities pane is us
describing what is what is the data that
we're trying to extract the explanation
pane this is where we're explaining the
features that's important for the photo
model to learn so the first thing you
have to do when we want to build any
kind of model is to find some positive
examples so we can do this for example
by just doing a plaint search for
addresses we might want to search for
say pine streets so
so we're gonna search for some example
of an address and we see at the bottom
here it found it found an address and
now because of our schema that we
defined ourselves we are going to to
label this particular example as being a
an address and I see it occurs here as
well
it's at its level medicine address now
our schema we say basic in address is
something as street as a pure box as a
city state and a zip code so we want to
explain this to the model by labeling
all the sub parts as well so well label
this part is straight C this happened
here as well
city seattle you'll see that as we label
something as a street we implicitly
label the street as not being a city of
the state is Washington and yeah we
don't have a sub but yeah we do as a
code so that's also good
so as we submit our label we can start
training a model and you'll see now in
our label pane we can see some of the
examples appearing here so this this
section here is an example of features
so this is where we explain to the the
system what why do we think is an
example is isn't address why it's part
of an address for example we could have
something like address words so if you
see words like with that may be address
or contact or location
this is give us some some clue of
whether it is a why it isn't address I'm
gonna move towards a new model that is a
bit more mature that we've added quite a
bit of labels or actually not that maybe
50 labels or so but it takes maybe 10 or
20 minutes to label a an extractor to
get to this point
okay so you can see that many many more
labels as we've added them the review
model is what helps us to debug the
system so you can see a bunch of red box
the bottom bunch of green boxes the top
so these are basically items that we've
labeled as being addresses so this box
is a place where we said this is an
address and the red ones is where we
label things as being not addresses so
these parts are labeled as red because
they're not addresses the the scale that
you see here is the confidence of our
current model as to whether it thinks
it's an address or not so ideally you
want all the green box to be at the top
meaning that things that we've labeled
as being addresses are being predicted
as addresses and you want all the red
things to be at the bottom meaning that
things have been labeled as not
addresses is being predicted as not
being addressed now everything you can
see that this helps us to debug and find
problems in our model for example this
one so this one is being predicted as
fairly positive that it is an address
but we've labeled it is not being
address so you can see here it thinks
this is a street it thinks my peer box
is the street this is wrong let's look
at this one so this one it thinks it's
not an address but we clearly labeled it
as being an address because it has a
peer box so this is part of the address
now the reason it made this mistake is
we haven't added a feature if to explain
to it what is a peer box so let's add a
feature so we call this feature in fact
let me just copy a couple of words so
we're gonna take some words that are
related to pure box of there are
different ways you could write pair but
if your dog barks Bo box like if you
look through several examples you'll see
Bo box being written in in different
ways so we add a new feature we call our
future peer box we add
a couple of words and now we have a new
feature if you now retrain our model
with this new information we see that it
learns now it correctly predicts our PA
box and our data is much better
separated so using using this this
technique we can we can easily train
extractors or classifiers to teach a
concept using no knowledge of machine
learning but only in domain knowledge
something that that is important is
having access to a large set of
unlabeled data you want to be able to
explore the unlabeled set so that you
can get some confidence that once you've
built a model you want to go through
this big set of unlabeled data and find
examples to make sure that your model is
doing ok for example if I if I were to
sample using predicted positives I
should be able to find an example that
is collect being correctly predicted so
this for example is a on the rest
we've got my street got the city state
it got this app so we take aways from
from this
is that basically one person can should
be able to teach a system without any
knowledge of machine learning or without
being engineer you should be able to
teach a system some concept that you
want to teach it and this knowledge
should be able to be transferable so if
I were to start building a model I
should be able to hand it off to Alisha
and say you can continue doing this
which is often a problem with machine
learning is that people with very
specific skills are not able to transfer
that knowledge to the next person also
we've we haven't really touched on this
in this particular demo yet but the idea
that you you can decompose a problem
into smaller problems for example if I
were to include something like a phone
number inside the address I could build
a smaller extractor that first extracts
the the phone number as part of my
addresses extractor so the idea to be
able to to decompose a problem into
smaller problems and build separate
extractors and compose extractors out of
other smaller extractors is something
like we feel it helps to us to scale
with complexity we mentioned that being
able to explore a large set of unlabeled
data is very important to to make sure
that the final model generalizes to to
two larger set of problems and not get
kind of stuck on on a small set of of
training examples we also feel that
software engineering tools such as
version control systems and things we've
learned from the software industry we
can actually apply the machine learning
to be able to share
share existing models if I could quickly
show you for example all the labels and
and features are actually stored in text
format so in our project where we added
a beer box feature you can say that this
is just plain text and so we can now use
this system searches get or CSV or some
version control system to get a version
history of our model over time and I can
also collaborate with other machine
teachers and ensure our models in that
way so this this is basically our
takeaway thank you for watching